l'équipe de rugby de saint quentin en
yvelines se mobilisent comme chaque
année pour des causes humanitaires cette
année c'est au profit de l'association
laurette fugain qui oeuvre contre la
leucémie rendez vous le 11 novembre au
stade du bout des clots s est à maurepas
bonsoir à olivier laval vous êtes en
charge de l'événementiel pour ce club on
sera lionel garrigues également qui en
est le président vous êtes venu avec
yves thème créateur du site internet de
l'association laurette fugain et
également du site internet du club de
rugby de saint quentin en yvelines c'est
vous qui avez fait le lien entre les
deux en fait la plus j'ai participé aux
liens mais c'est vrai que en discutant
avec avec le président et il s'avérait
qu'il y avait déjà une attirance pour
pour cette cause de paris vous
l'expliquera mieux quoi je penche par
rapport à l'expérience qu'il avait eu
avec le club ami de athis mons on
recense reprise est basée à montigny le
bretonneux tout en images point commun
cette cause justement on va entrer dans
le détail de l'organisation et de cette
manifestation du 11 novembre mais cette
cause déjà c'était une cause qui vous
touche est particulièrement où vous
aviez envie puisque vous avez participé
à la création du site internet de de
laurette fugain donc c'est vrai que on
participe avec toutes les équipes depuis
deux ans maintenant à l'accompagnement
de l'association laurette fugain on a
participé à la génèse de la refonte
complète du site internet qui est un
élément de communication essentiel pour
eux et et non seulement pour le tout
public mais surtout aussi pour les
malades eux-mêmes qui ont leur blog qui
hébergeait sur ce site là et qui est un
moyen essentiel de communiquer parce que
les gens quand ils ont là le fini et qui
sont à l'hôpital ils sont dans leur
bulle est donc le seul moyen de
communiquer avec l'extérieur c'est ce
site pour ce site est extrêmement
important et est donc avec toutes les
équipes on a voulu porter cette cause là
et accompagné non seulement pour la
création mais depuis on pour toutes les
mises à jour et de l'accompagnement de
du site la vie du site de l'évolution du
site internet
des valeurs communes justement être
l'association laurette fugain le club de
rugby pour passer de l'un à l'autre
quand vous avez développé les sites il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de valeurs
communes c'est déjà la valeur du partage
ce qu'il éléments fin je trouve
fondamental c'est aussi pour ça que j'ai
voulu accompagner le club de sky rugby
parce qu'il porte haut ses couleurs de
partage d'amitié je trouve de fraternité
il faisait déjà donc cet
événementiel caritatif mais j'ai envie
de dire que là avec cette année avec
l'association laurette fugain j'ai
l'impression que ça prend encore plus
d'ampleur de par la mobilisation qui a
et il invite tout le monde à venir
dimanche pour pourvoir ce magnifique ton
puis je reprécise 1 que l'association
laurette fugain oeuvre contre la
leucémie elle se bat pour informer
sensibiliser sur les dons de vie et pour
que la déficience en dons ne puisse plus
être un obstacle à la guérison des
malades on va se tournent à présent vers
les responsables du club de saint
quentin en yvelines de rugby va chaque
année vous organisez une cause justement
tourner vers l'humanitaire vers le
social au profit d'une association c'est
pas une première ce n'est pas une
première effectivement dans l'esprit
général du saint quentin en yvelines
rugby et donc de l'ensemble du bureau et
de ses membres il est acté que chaque
année nous contribuons nous nous
inscrivons dans une démarche caritative
en parallèle bien évidemment du sport
que nous servons qui est l'ovalie a
avant tout en rappelant effectivement et
ils veulent a dit l'essentiel de ces
valeurs là qui sont effectivement le
collectif la fraternité l'aide la main
tendue depuis deux ans nous avons
effectivement eu l'occasion d'organiser
des actions caritatives il ya deux ans
regarde par exemple des sinistrés du var
lorsqu'il ya eu des soucis d'inondations
l'an dernier nous nous sommes associés
effectivement avec le club d'athis-mons
dans une opération au profit des restos
du coeur et cette année comme bien le
dire par des concours de circonstances
qui sont liées effectivement une
prestation de sites internet mais
également une une autre cohérence avec
l'équipe d'athis-mons que le président
vous présentera nous avons décidé
effectivement d'apporter notre aide à la
sensibilisation
contre la leucémie par l'intermédiaire
de l'association laurette fugain le
programme du dimanche 11 novembre match
de championnat de sky rugby affronte
pour ce championnat athis mons à 15
heures lever de rideau avec du rugby
féminin le stade français et face à
crépy en valois c'est à 13h30 à partir
de 13h30 il faudra donc être du côté de
maurepas ce club d'athis-mons justement
et est partenaire avec le skyrim autour
de de ces manifestations vous organisés
régulièrement il est le feu adversaires
et partenaires j'ai entendu club ami
mais c'est tout à fait parce que dans le
rugby
est un adolescent il y en a même un sale
week-end à oublier
passera pas à côté maintenant elle est
l'élément déclencheur ça a effectivement
été après que nous ayons nous même
participé comme l'a dit olivier
à cette journée restos du coeur n'est
dernière avec le club dati semences à la
demande du club d'athis mons nous avons
su que l'un des joueurs venait de perdre
son sa petite fille je prends d'une
leucémie et qu'il militait lui-même dans
l'association laurette fugain ça a été
l'élément déclencheur la boucle est
bouclée avec l'action du stand vous avez
pu après c'est apprécié comme il
s'approprie en plus d'être le
prestataire internet de la fondation
laurette fugain 70 il s'approprie aussi
lui-même le
la mission même de la fondation laurette
fugain donc voilà la boucle est bouclée
à travers cet élément là et puis et puis
malheureux ce malheureux événement qui a
touché un joueur d'athis-mons donc ces
voix-là l'écho que nous voulions donner
à cette journée concrètement comment
vous allez récolter les fonds axés en
mac sera payante alors l'accès au match
n'est pas payé est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un
match de niveau promotion d'honneur donc
une sensibilisation par effectivement
distribution de flyers ces incitations
au don sera fait auprès du public
l'ensemble des dons sous formes
financier sera récoltée auprès de
représentants du saint quentin en
yvelines et de l'association laurette
fugain et la recette complète de la
partie effectivement festive autour de
cet événement sera entièrement reversée
à l'association laurette fugain en
général vous réussissez à collecter
combien là il s'agirait de bizet sans
trop se mouiller à ce jour avec un
simple fonctionnement par exemple de la
buvette autour d'un match de championnat
de ce type là c'est de la classe 500
euros je vous le disais tout à l'heure
nous avons aussi le plaisir d'accueillir
en match et l'âge 1 6 un match féminin
le stade français qui va jouer qu'entre
crépy en valois nous allons diffuser
auprès de ces deux clubs là également
cette opération humanitaire
l'ensemble de nos partenaires ont été
sensibilisés l'ensemble des institutions
rugbystique et municipale ainsi que de
la communauté d'agglo ont reçu
l'incitation à venir nous voir donc nous
espérons un public nombreux un public
nombreux s'est forcé en source de gains
que ça soit des biens financiers au sens
des dons mais il est également peut-être
et c'est aussi très important il ne faut
pas voir que l'aspect financier des dons
des dons de plasma des dons de
plaquettes des dons d'organes pour aider
effectivement ceux qui ont moins de
chance et qui malheureusement sont
touchés par cette terrible maladie et
sensibiliser en tout cas faire connaître
la cause de cette association laurette
fugain qui se mobilisent association
évinoise qui est né dans les îles le
matin l'armistice commémoration et puis
l'après midi on va déterrer la hache de
guerre puisqu'il aura un match de
championnat c'est important aussi de
s'imposer juste une petite parenthèse 2
victoires 1 nul 7 bilan pour l'instant
de cette équipe c'est non ces deux
défaites et 7 nuls
et deux défaites jeu sans utiliser la
méthode coué je ne m'en satisfais pas
bien entendu de ces deux défaites mais
je note que quand même les deux équipes
qui nous ont battus sont les deux
équipes qui caracole en haut du tableau
donc ça c'est de marier les excès et les
joueurs les joueurs sont motivés pour
dimanche affronter athis-mons l'appui
pyromètre remettre les pendules à
l'heure qu'on dit et je pense que je
pense qu'on sera au rendez vous les
joueurs eux se consacre pleinement à
cette mission je vais les voir juste
après votre entretien
justement jauger le niveau de motivation
et les motiver en tout cas pour
s'imposer lors de ce match qui aura un
goût particulier une saveur particulière
puisqu'il faudra faire venir le public
pour sensibiliser à cette opération de
soutien à laurède fut également à
l'association à partir de 13h30 pour le
lever de rideau et puis à 15 heures pour
ce match de championnat merci à tous les
trois d'être venu sur le plateau le 7-8
de ce soir est presque terminée une
dernière information politique cette
fois ci le député ump des yvelines jean
frédéric poisson interpellé le
gouvernement sur le dispositif des
emplois d'avenir il estime qu'il manque
au moins 250 millions d'euros pour payer
les aides aux emplois en 2013 et que le
coût de formation qui sera au minimum de
750 millions d'euros n'a pas été
budgétés le ministère du travail
conteste cette déclaration les
discussions vont se poursuivre à
l'assemblée au sénat également autour du
projet de loi de finances les
discussions qui se poursuivaient c'est
de la fin de cette édition du 7 8 du 8
novembre prochaine diffusion à 19h à
22h30 et minuit et le 7-8 ce week end
vous sera présentée dès vendredi à 18h
par catherine sous la tôle je
retrouverai lundi avec de nouveaux
invités excellente soirée
ok